uh you were just shooting a video in la
and
uh what i thought was amazing i just
scrolling on instagram is a picture of
you and j
coles and i was like oh cole yeah that
was fire shouts to j
cole it was that the first time you guys
met in my life
he like my respect level for him without
the already like you know from afar
saluted everything he'd do big fan of
his music
but um i was shooting a video uh on
sunset he was driving by
randomly and saw me and pulled over
hopped out
and i'm saying i was against a lot of
people i know would have been just like
oh what up boy like and i'm saying they
kept it pushing
he he hopped out we exchanged numbers
you know what i'm saying i was at combo
man he just like i thought he would have
been man cool i'm saying i just told him
i've been wanting to get with you big
fan of your work
he said boomerang well he stopped too
because he saw you so he must be a fan
of your one that was dope
like i said i never met him before we
never dm'd
we never that was one hip-hop connection
i didn't have you know i mean yeah is uh
i have you ever um previously tried to
reach out to cole or anything i feel
like
musically you guys would mesh so well um
no not not not personally or direct um
i was working with wyclef maybe four
years three or four years ago and i know
clef knew him
and i mean we spoke about it right never
never put it together
but honestly with me i like when [ __ ]
like that happened
rather than somebody connecting it right
right just letting that be
handing that [ __ ] i'd rather just meet
you or we just be at the same place same
time
and then naturally you know i mean that
was dope yeah that's fire uh
and then well dmx was there too soon as
j cole pulled off dmx
hopped out i said damn this is the hell
of a day
same corner i'm like this is the corner
of the bill this is the corner
shout out to dmx man dmx got that dad
bod popping right now